a deep sigh and then an incredulous
silence
this is a historical moment and for the
hundreds of fdp supporters gathered in
berlin it's a painful one too
the german parliament without the fdp
it's tough to take for these people but
the party has seen their support drop by
two-thirds it's a disastrous performance
lead candidate rana broodler and party
leader philip rusler struggled to put a
brave face on the result
it's clear that this is the worst result
the fdp has recorded so far
it's a difficult hour for the fdp
and as lead candidate
i take responsibility
the name is stephen
it's the most bitter saddest hour for
the free democratic party
the grassroots members are in shock
it was clear that the fdp's entrance
into parliament was on the line
opinion polls have been saying so for
months
but now the worst has happened and the
party's supporters are gutted
we knew it was going to be tight
but personally i didn't think this was
going to happen
i thought it was going to be bad but not
under five percent
a really poor result i'm speechless
we need to get back up and see how we
can put things back on track
that's going to dominate discussions in
the party over the next few days
what's the correct path forward the fdp
needs a thorough overhaul that's clear
to party leader philip rossler after
these elections in this bitter result
for the free democrats